now obviously you're seeing what's going
on with america with
trump now finally you know the
transitions taking place with biden
coming in with kamala harris
and we saw what happened at the capitol
and i'm i'm sure you saw that in um
uh in israel on the news but uh who
you did or you didn't yeah who
constructed of course and i saw the
origin the cnn and fox and the audience
what'd you think about it what were your
thoughts on that well i'm
it it made me it made me very sick
what i saw what what do you think in the
direction
and look being being israeli
and i don't i don't hide
the fact from for a moment
that israeli existence
and israeli security to a
very large extent is dependent on
the us i try to judge the
events of the last few days through the
prism
of what is the what is the interest of
of israel in in in this
development and i'm sorry to say that
the first point that hit me
was that
america in the last few days
has lost its
its prime statue
around the world israel america since
the end of world war ii was the
uh the the lighthouse
of of democracy of democracy
of liberal democracy of marketplace
economy of freedom
of equality to the rest of the world
america since the end of world war ii to
this day
was the guarantee and the
and the leader of of of the western
world
and after the events of uh of uh
the last two three days
i i don't see how american
can convince
its other allies around the world
not to mention the adversaries
that the uh a
best form of
of regime is
is is is democracy
pick any any one leader among the
among the uh
or the guy in brazil or the
guy in the philippines or the guy or the
the rulers of the of the of the middle
east
and can you argue and convince them that
the
the democracy is the is the preferable
and the best um
uh um regime in order to
you know to uh to build the world to
bring more harmony to build equality
what are you suggesting what do you what
do you what are you suggesting
is there a suggestion in that statement
of yours
well my i i i by far
more modest than trying to uh
trying to define the the future of the
world but i can tell you a
few words about the uh
possible eventual development in in
in in the middle east
regarding the situation in the in the
middle east
in the conflict between israel and
and the and the palestinians
i believe that the the
the development which took place
in recent weeks namely the upgrade
of relationship between israel and the
and some of the emirates and morocco
is is is good news is very is very
important it it
first and foremost it transmitted a very
strong
signal to the palestinians that listen
guys
we were supporting you since 1945
deep today but the world today is not
what it used to be
all in in the past and you have to
reckon with the changes that are taking
place in the
in the middle east now israel is not
anymore
our enemy our enemy is extreme
islam being represented mainly by
iran who's pursuing
a nuclear military capability
this is the real threat now so you
palestinians
it's it's high time for you
to change your policy and
and and but there is there is an
additional
condition to uh
to what i'm saying one is that uh
the president-elect or the president uh
president biden should um
adopt a strategy that
the us is not leaving the middle east
and not only because of uh israel and
the palestinians because of many other
reasons because of the
because of the security of the of the
world
because the the russians
are competing with them because the
chinese are competing with them
because america
need to go on leading the free world
and and and leading the free world it
means to
to have a foot also in the in the middle
east
you should now bring in saudi arabia
and and create a new axis
of u.s leading
saudi arabia israel
egypt and jordan with which we have a
peace already
and the emulate vis-a-vis
the threats of iran and turkey
and within this framework the
palestinian
will will be in a position that
whether they like it or not they'll have
to change their attitude and
and and policy and to become
a partner to a solution for the conflict
with israel so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye